professor albrecht von lucke bleibt es
wirklich spannend denn wenn man die
disco demoskopen sich anschaut und ihre
zahlen dann ist das rennen doch gelaufen
ist das so
nein keineswegs die abstände sind bei
weitem nicht so klar dass nicht doch
noch in den letzten drei tagen die
wenigen prozent und es geht um ganz ganz
wenige von olaf scholz zu armin laschet
überlaufen könnte die entscheidende
frage wird sein denn es sind ja noch
hinreichend viele unentschlossen es sind
noch viele die an doch vielleicht an die
urne gehen können die entscheidende
frage wird sein zieht diese drohkulisse
die armin laschet schon lange aufbaut
also die angst vor rot rot grün zieht
sie vielleicht heute mit dieser gesamte
runde noch einmal auf das ist eine neue
konstellation hier mag es auch gewisse
sympathie bekundungen der linkspartei zu
gunsten von olaf scholz geben also die
frage ist noch im raum hält dieser
vorsprung wenn er allerdings hält dann
wäre das ein erdbeben dann wäre das was
sie vorhin beschrieben haben das ende
der ära merkel nach 16 jahren fast so
etwas wie eine revolution denn eines ist
klar die cdu/csu wird auf einen
historischen tiefstand stürzen es geht
nur noch verlasse darum das schlimmste
zu verhindern hinter olaf scholz zu
landen jetzt könnte es natürlich auch
umgekehrt ausgehen diejenigen die sagen
acht den olaf scholz den finde ich
eigentlich einen guten mann na ja wir
wissen nur nicht ganz genau was hinter
ihm steht in der spd da stehen ja doch
viele linke hinter ihm und dann könnte
es ja auch noch sein dass er wirklich
mit den roten zusammengeht die
unsicherheit ist doch enorm groß und es
könnte doch auch tatsächlich dazu kommen
dass bei einer rot-rot-grünen koalition
viele wähler sehr enttäuscht sind weil
das wollen die meisten offenbar nun doch
nicht sie haben völlig recht das wollen
die meisten nicht sie können aber
eigentlich absolut sicher sein dass ohne
stolz dass auch nicht will sein großes
dilemma besteht darin er muss für seine
ich sage es linke wählerschaft also die
vor allem starken juso truppen da muss
er die hoffnung auf rot rot grün
aufrechterhalten er will sie nicht dem
mobilisieren außerdem gibt es so etwas
wie ein parteitagsbeschluss der deutlich
gesagt hat man ist auch bereit gespräche
mit der linkspartei zu führen also er
fühlt sich darin ein stück weit gebunden
vielleicht das wird immer noch in
stellung gebracht will er auch eine
weitere koalitionsoption haben um danach
mehr druck auf die fdp
ausüben zu können dann doch in eine
ampel koalition einzutreten aber im kern
ist olaf scholz alles andere als ein
sympathisant der linkspartei diese
konstellation ist eine drohkulisse aber
sie haben völlig recht ich bin gespannt
ob die heutige runde er noch mehr
anstalten macht seitens stolz dass er
deutlich macht es kommt auf diese
koalition nicht zu denn das ist
tatsächlich seine vielleicht größte
schwachstelle er räumt die angst nicht
aus obwohl eigentlich eher von seiner
haltung keinerlei bereitschaft hat eine
rot rot grüne koalition einzugehen weil
die zweite schwachstelle für die spd
könnte die tatsache sein dass der fdp
chef lindner relativ klar erklärt hat er
könne eigentlich am allerbesten mit der
cdu und wenn der abstand nicht sehr groß
ist könnte das ja auch passieren und
wenn die cdu als zweiter ins ziel geht
sie haben völlig recht historisch hat es
das immer wieder gegeben helmut kohl war
76 bei weitem stärker als helmut schmidt
trotzdem konnte helmut schmidt mit der
spd weiterregieren weil er die fdp an
seiner seite hatte aber wir dürfen uns
doch eines nicht zu dramatisch wären
vorstellen stellen sie sich vor herr
laschet kommt tatsächlich als zweiter
ins ziel mit einem absturz der cdu csu
von round about 89 vielleicht zehn
prozent also von 33 prozent auf 23 24
die spd liegt vor ihm dh die spd würde
um fünf prozent nach oben wandern dann
wäre das alleine von der symbolkraft ein
solcher misstrauens befund gegen armin
laschet speziell aber auch gegen die
union dass ich mir beim besten willen
nicht vorstellen kann dass bei dieser
zweiten position der cdu csu das noch
als ein echter wählerauftrag begriffen
würde und etwas anderes viel wichtigeres
kommt noch hinzu es gibt ja nach wie vor
einen starken mann in der union das ist
markus söder und die csu das hat sie
bereits jetzt erklärt hat überhaupt kein
interesse als zweitstärkste partei einen
koalition unter einem schwachen kanzler
laschet zu bilden der csu ist mehr daran
gelegen eine schwache regierung unter
olaf scholz vor sich her zu treiben
damit man in zwei jahren in bayern ein
starkes ergebnis erzielt es gibt also
enorme fliehkräfte in der union dort ist
keineswegs ausgemacht wer überhaupt
regieren will ja wir sind gespannt nicht
nur auf den sonntag nicht nur auf heute
so sondern im zweifelsfall auch auf die
wochen danach denn dann wird sie
entscheiden so ganz eindeutig wird das
wahrscheinlich nicht ausgehen danke an
sie für die kommentierung da gehen